when we told you about frankie montas
and how things have gone for him since
the all-star break
in even a little more detail over the
last three starts 1.31 era 22 punch-outs
and just over 20 innings pitched
and it's been three very good starts in
a row that last one came against the
detroit tigers got through six and
two-thirds innings would love to see a
little more of that tonight from frankie
montos
counts to short
there's charges he's got it out at
second to throw to first and that is a
double play six score three these turn
it on jose abreu here come the athletics
in the bottom of the first
and here's dallas geicle he's going to
look to right the ship a little bit
today he's struggled so far this year
but he's looking to get into form
hopefully to get a playoff spot in that
rotation or in as a long man in the
bullpen
change up flared to left and a dive for
andrew vaughan for route number one
well nice play by andrew on cal berkeley
night at the oakland coliseum isn't that
ironic don't you think great play by
andrew to come in here this is a great
thing too for a pitcher okay my guys are
behind me they're playing good d i can
attack the zone they're going to make
plays for me
on the ground moncada in one motion with
an exceptional player that's a great
play right there
awesome play by morgana
[Music]
two-two that falls jack to left-center
field to the wall marta and it's off the
wall
yeah smashes another baseball for a
leadoff double in the second inning
yikes
he can't even believe what he's doing he
thought he knocked it out of the
ballpark
grounded to second harrison's got it
flips to anders onto first and that is a
double play
four six three double play to keep the
white sox off the board nicely done by
harrison and andrews so white sox do not
score bottom of the second coming up
so matt chapman mark canna and john
gomes to face dallas keiko
and that one's so deep to left field
vaughn is back and
that baby's gone
history repeats it's a fourth home run
for chapman against dallas kuiper in his
career in the easy one nothing
matt chapman
jumped all over
a little flutter and change piece
pack your bags chappie
[Music]
swinging a bit strike three pikel
with his first strikeout
something cool
to right on a line goodwin's on the hunt
and there is out number three we'll find
out what gordon bought the charlotte
knights when we come back
[Applause]
high pop-up
behind first olson hustling out pinder
coming in and it's going to be matt
olson
calm
cool
collected
makes the catch
hernandez the runner in first two outs
harrison down in shallow right field
with the shift on from okada
and he got it swinging down and in good
pitch that's the first strikeout for
frankie montas we're going to the bottom
of the third with the a's leading one to
nothing
[Applause]
marty a line shot off the glove or the
leg of
hernandez the second baseman marty's
gonna try for two and martay's gonna
make it how about that
gaining the admiration and the respect
of his opponents and his predecessors
and jose braves
and misses so derek jeter
led the group and you'll be able to
speak to this much better than i but
grabbed
chapman
first double play how about that a
little bit of everybody got a piece of
it
we'll go with the one four five six
seven eight three double for something
it's a double play that's all that
matters
saying no thank you to a large sum of
money
[Applause]
hannah drives one to left bond's not
gonna get this one
hangs off the wall picks it up near the
track
and that is a one-off double for market
so one nothing a's
fourth inning one out and now the pitch
of the gomes he lines one in the center
sinks for a base center in front of
robert up to third is canada gonna wave
him home the throw comes in to the
middle of the diamond no relay by abrayu
canna slides in safely and rbi single
for yon gomes and he doubles the a's
lead to two nothing
[Applause]
called strike three it's been a strike
all night long we told you about it and
there it was again
davis can't believe it
they astros fans
no no they're white sox fans
slap down the line garcia rips it into
the bullpen
he's going to go for second and cannas
throw is late it's a double for laori
garcia and a good start in the fifth
goodwin pass to diving harrison into
right field
garcia chops his steps at third the sox
have runners at the corners with nobody
out
swinging and a miss
vaughn chased a high fastball
he's the first out of the inning for
cesar hernandez calling two strikes
peter inside olson double clutch and he
threw it wide he never had the rhythm
the socks are on the board hernandez
into second base goodwin into third it's
two to one
that could not have worked out any
better for the white sox
shallow center marte's coming in he'll
get there and he's got it so frankie
montos limits the damage one run for the
white sox we're going to the bottom of
the fifth
so one out here's man olsen
[Music]
that's gonna be a base in left center
field
read all the way by albus andrews he
scores the throw to third is late the
throw to second is going to be in time
to get olson who will now be in a
rundown harrison
is going to stay at third olson is out
he's going to run it's three to one
[Music]
the ball pops away from gomez abraham
will go to second so it's a strikeout
the sheets waves at a pitch
back-to-back strikeouts and the 3-2
pitch will be on the way and montage
throws and a fastball the inside corner
ring him up strike three call
perfect pitch the pinder hits for the
third time he's lined out to white round
it out to short
reach for pumped on the right field line
and it is fair
here comes john gomes kant says waving
him home and the relay throw sails over
everybody gomes scores all the way to
third is pinder and it's four to one the
eas lead
coming out to get kykel with two outs
here in the bottom of the sixth inning
and that's a face in left field hooked
it in the left pinner comes in to score
and it's now five to one
and abyss four consecutive strikeouts
for montas now he's got seven
yeah swung at the first pitch or not
if he did you gotta take a pitch
yes took okay hey there is the first
base hit for romy gonzalez so in a game
that at five to one might end up being a
loss
this will be the memorable thing for the
white sox team that that young man an
18th round pick
romy gonzalez has his first major league
hit that's great awesome congrats romy i
know his family is probably watching or
there
and that's a swinger you're gonna miss
vaughn strikes out chaffin comes in
and the a's break their four-game losing
streak and they get a much much
needed win